obviously you and sean have been working
on
detroit too for a long time since 2018.
yeah i feel like you know this has
been highly anticipated house
um how long ago did you and nas decide
to fully
connect for king's disease it's crazy
because
like like you said we was working on
sean um for a minute
uh we was already in a groove with that
so i was just you know from talking to
him every day working on his records and
listening to records that wasn't mine
but that he was going to put on the
album because i'm executive producing it
i just got so deep in a bag that by the
time me and nas length was
was it was only february of this year
that was six years six months ago i mean
it's [ __ ] in september right before
the panda right before the pandemic
that's what's crazy about king's disease
people think it's like
oh they they took the cove and [ __ ] but
we we could throw the king's disease
before this [ __ ] cracked off before he
was all in the house before
all the corona all that so um yeah we
we connected in february and just did a
record and we just kept doing songs and
before we looked up we had an album and
it didn't even take long to get the base
of it like maybe a
couple weeks max wow